Wesley right Weston British Mason now is
just the last game you play for the
preview just now how'd you know the RIT
for c6 you know that's the kerosene okay
Knight upgrades that we normally do you
don't have a system yet okay well in
general the principle for facing the
caro-kann appeared French
position what it gave you the center
usually the best advice even though it
sounds simple is to take and even the
best theoretical lines pretty much all
involved with same principle which is to
grab the center and then when the
attacks on the lights course you have a
couple choices you can gain some space
which will potentially give you an
attack over here and a lot of the lines
or you can trade and try to gain an
initiative on the on the pawn and you
can actually just defend the pawn with
the night but in the end of it evaluate
which pawn is better this one today
which one's better deep on or c1
it is you know why it's further advanced
in the center which means it is
controlling slightly more important
squares some old-school dudes who
embedded some principles like that I
don't really agree with it but they
would always say a pawn on the fourth
rank is worth two points whereas this
one is only worth one point and the
reason they said that though is because
however furthest advance your army is
that's how many important squares they
can for look at the Knights here he has
a potential to attack the King or
something right so if a knight's farther
advance the point is that the pawns that
are further advanced like this are
evaluated as stronger than the other
plot it's called a space advantage with
more space your pieces have more options
all right options equals power and then
power use better tactics so it sounds
simple but that's actually chess in a
nutshell and you're all that's simple
but ok so defending the pawn and trying
to get a bigger Center is the most
common and probably most effective way
to deal with this when you play Knight
of 3 and they play decide you can play
this way this is actually a two Knights
system against the Carroll Khan when I
did I don't think you were playing that
because you know the theory right you
were just sort of developing yeah sort
of yes
yeah this isn't bad it's sort of Silla
everything I just said about the karo
pollen and game space advantage and sort
of how you evaluate those conditions
also applies to a lot of French
positions as well okay so this isn't bad
I'm just trying to give you some sort of
general thing to think about
now after East six which is kind of a
passively room to play probably the best
thing to do is to again try to play in
the center right you play Bishop you -
one question I would ask you where would
you put the pony if I played deep or you
can't go here fYI all traffic so just
like that you're backing up and I'm not
sure that you really got a lot out of
that development plan so that's another
reason why you might want have occupied
the center with your own okay there
should be 297 d3 Bishop d6 hassles Queen
to c7 okay you play rook e1 and then
Knight f6 Bishop of 194 you say cheese
okay it's not bad at all I mean the way
you're approaching it
so g3p castles and you play Bishop you
too so you feeling kettled by hands the
old university went around you know what
up being keto is okay so that's what you
did right you didn't develop the day
you're going to went around that's not
bad I mean your king side is going to be
very safe in this position 52 to do
takes me 4d takes e4 he takes e5 okay
Bishop to c4 c5
[Music]
yeah but he's attacking upon so how you
depending on you did but what if I
played this you actually will get out
Justin so now you take your nine here
it's fantastic move I love defending
attacking the same thing you're awesome
but it's risky as well just this isn't
that battle move yes it wastes time but
the position has changed so because
there's an over file and it makes some
sense for him to come to attack the
party right I might have played this
anyway and if you take here I might take
here and when you move the knight
something like this to get get an attack
on the Queen and my pieces are sort of
coming to life that's a little bit
far-fetched for you guys I guess to
calculate those kind of moves but one
other move that may not be so
far-fetched that we didn't see when you
block with a knight is to use the x-ray
whenever there are pieces lined up on
the same diagonal or file you should
consider all possible tactics there look
at blacks position see what he can play
he actually has a move that takes
advantage of your position being on this
diagonal I said you can take and after
King takes e5 into population you okay
and your only way to defend is this
which is actually okay but if I make a
big tray probably in the end we evaluate
that black is happy just because I
weakened your King side and your King is
open so what could you have done besides
Knight to d4 is the question maybe
nothing actually
[Music]
but you might have also considered just
defending with the rook because if he
takes and gives up a night mission for
working upon who gets the best out of
them do you do I the minor pieces are
typically better than the book in the
pond in the middle game so that that may
have been better even rookie to if you
don't want to go back you keep the rook
on the e-file you could kick his pony
out extern okay so that might even
better but he didn't see it in that he
defended with this Knight which is also
kind of weird maybe you should have
played this one I don't know but then
you get Bishop III that's good I cleaned
it e6 Knight f3 you want to trade Queens
huh and he says okay I will oblige he
trades then you trade so we got big
trades going on
nice c5 594 rookie 197 h3 okay this is
good you're sort of pushing him back a
little bit I don't know that I'm a huge
fan of this move are you headed for this
square so then I'm not a huge fan of it
because you're going out of your way for
one move Bret that can be stopped very
easily and these pieces I don't really
feel it on their best wares
here's what I want to point out what's
the biggest problem with blacks position
right now the night is sideline I would
agree that that's definitely one I'm
kind of looking at a bigger bum
yeah actually not just the bishop but
the whole development of the Queen side
here
this Bishop geeking out which means the
rook can't get out which means you can't
really challenge your open file so one
way to take advantage of that is a move
like we know it's funny I want to
suggest something like rook d6 and
double Brooks and really dominate but
maybe he'll play nine to five so one one
move it then all the sudden becomes the
best move you bind when you start
thinking logically as this move machine
or maybe keeping the night out
and now his night is real problems right
these are no real real-world issues here
so that might have been a really good
move I don't like you can't go over
plans on the edge of the board like this
and expect to be successful unless
there's already a weakness or if you
have the Queen's on the board and you're
going for a checkmate attack this is
kind of the wrong approach
he plays Knight b6 and then you can pop
that which is fantastic it's a good move
attack but again he places you now
that's the problem is now watch why you
played b3 that's a good move it's
restrictive King g7 in G - okay I still
would be trying to double my rooks on
the open file or something
I might even play another restrictive
move besides this like Igor because then
if he goes here
I play a five you really have a big bind
here so I'm sort of being nitpicky to
say that what the better moves are your
position is definitely better than his
his rooks are disconnected he's
underdeveloped but part of the reason
I'm doing that is just to help you for
future games right we only review the
past to prepare for the future that's it
otherwise she was beating yourself up no
point doing it so you're reviewing the
game and try to take some principles
forward and I would just say that when
your opponent has a big weakness like
this that's you know lack of development
uncoordinated pieces you really want to
make sure it stays that way you want to
take advantage of that witness and so
looking for ways to continue to make it
make us like difficult to untangle
otherwise you're he's going to do
everything you can to get play here
and now the rooks are connected you try
to get here just in time but then he
defends and you get him out but now look
he's actually gotten out and his books
are connected maybe a little better for
him than it was before and I need to
move the knight and try to kind of
slowly unwind so that's all we're trying
to take advantage of what the biggest
problem is so you play King teach you
and he starts to get the knight back
into play but I don't like what you're
doing here you're kind of messing around
h6 94 f5 over you put on the Sun and you
never miss a chance to on facade get it
but usually people do you know why it's
human nature don't get a chance to do it
often
so every time you get a change yeah
don't opus on if you get mating next
move right
protip pro tip don't off the Sun if you
get baited
thanks t5 what yeah you missed the
defensive right and then Smashville
smash bill it's over now boom Tim the
Knight takes rook e3 and now it's just
clean up right in Mother Russia they
call this a matter of technique okay
that's right
Knight takes f8 Knight takes that play
brookie 396
mission Chi 495 chop delicious h4 very
good 96 broke up 3g pied and you say I
don't care
honey bad you don't care right you go
take it take it off rook takes f6 and
it's over I mean nobody defendant light
fantastic smiley face for me this nope
we all learned something here we got
closer
you